[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre cette
fille 3 ira vite vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro le sommaire de ce jeudi 4
juillet la plus ancienne fête foraine de
prononce accueille les visiteurs depuis
le 28 juin
ils peuvent profiter de cette 360
septième édition jusqu'au 18 août
nous leur avons rendu visite la troupe
d'art musical et dramatique d'elancourt
maurepas fête ses 30 ans samedi elle
donnant un spectacle spécial au prisme
jérémy calado président de l'association
sera notre invité
le zoo safari de thoiry et france
miniature de nouvelles surprises pour
les familles nous présenterons ces
espaces déjà ouvert 360 cette enquête se
déroule en forêt de saint germain en
laye la fête des loges a démarré pour
cette semaine c'est jusqu'au 18 août
l'événement forains a beau être le plus
ancien de france
il présente cette année encore quelques
nouveautés reportage ambiance de grieg
aurait canale et patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est sa première alors que qui vous a
tous les manèges sera pas cette année ce
sera l'année prochaine
que ce soit pour une balade en famille
ou des sensations fortes entre amis la
fête des loges à plein de ressources
pour cette 367e les visiteurs peuvent
découvrir plus de 200 animations stands
jeux
et bien sûr les traditionnels manèges je
pense que c'est merveilleux c'était
génial vraiment génial et bien c'est
ques et c'est plus convivial que la
foire du trône qui est très grande a
fait lâche un peu plus convivial et on
respire c'est mieux si certains sont
venus pour un moment de détente d'autres
ont bien sûr profité de la visite en
forêt de saint germain en laye pour
monter dans les attractions les plus
impressionnantes et le courage n'est pas
à bloc chez tout le monde n'a pas les
sensations fortes
j'ai peur qu'il leur laisse aller c'est
pas mal et tu crois juste que nous
entendons ça justement des sensations
fortes ou on aime ça donc on choisit les
malaises les plus ascensionnel c'est la
première et la seule donc ouais non là
c'est moi ça nous a retourné un petit
peu le coeur mais sympa vous avez
jusqu'au 18 août pour profiter de la
fête des loges plus de deux millions de
visiteurs sont attendus sur place
c'était
[Musique]
elle permet à des jeunes et des adultes
passionnés de théâtre de se produire et
jouer depuis 30 ans l'association tandem
organise pour l'occasion un spectacle
spécial ce samedi 6 juillet au prisme à
elancourt jérémy calado vous êtes le
président bonjour bonjour alors est ce
que vous venez d'écrire un peu cette
association de tandem
alors s'il ne sache aucune commun qui
fête ses 30 ans cette année elle a été
créée en 1989 en novembre exactement
j'ai pas la date de jour exact mais
voilà et voilà c'est une association qui
est qui qui essaye d'apporter aux gens
du du plaisir en faisant du théâtre
qu'on essaye de l'essai de monter plutôt
des spectacles assez sur le comique
voilà on essaie de détendre les gens on
a voilà on joue deux fois par an à peu
près un nom
la troupe joue en général au début le
début de chaque année l'espace albert
camus a donc à maurepas et après les
ateliers c'est soit à camus soit au
prisme en fonction des années de ce
qu'on peu de ce qu'on peut faire des
salles qu'on peut trouver parce qu'en
fait c'est un peu une troupe des anciens
il ya un noyau dur qui sait ce qu'ils
gèrent l'association ogrocki voilà qui
sent le cul qui l'animent et il ya en
plus des ateliers enfants et adultes les
mardis alors vous en est le président
depuis 13 ans il s'est passé quoi en
trésorerie et des moments phares a eu
des moments phares oui il ya eu il ya eu
des spectacles qui nous ont tenus à
vraiment vraiment à coeur parce que
c'est voilà une prochaine pièce la
méthode olivier on a joué plusieurs fois
fin là c'était une pièce marquante
il ya eu une année aussi où on a eu des
soucis de droits par un spectacle et du
coup on s'est retrouvés un mois un mois
de la date son spectacle donc il a fallu
improviser en un mois mais du coup ça a
fait un spectacle que les gens ont
apprécié qu'on a apprécié jouer donc un
spectacle un peu voilà comme ça sur loeb
en quoi justement pour les 30 ans j'en
avais préparé un autre de spectacle un
peu rétrospective pour nous décrire
c'est ça donc on a choisi des pièces
qu'on a aimé jouer ou des pièces qu'on
aurait aimé jouer mais juste des
extraits du coup voilà où des on a aussi
écrit une partie du spectacle
voilà on a essayé de c'était vraiment
pour se faire plaisir et voilà et les
adhérents qui sont arrivés cette année
où les quelques années avant au fil leur
présentait aussi des textes qu'on qu'ils
vont pas forcément jouer
voilà et on essaye de faire un final un
peu festif pour bien fêter ça fait effet
voilà fidall anniversaire on va dire
même acheté de la danse voilà on a
ajouté de la danse donc c'est le
challenge de cette année faire une
partie une partie un peu comédie
musicale on va dire donc voila c'était
le challenge de cette année ils s'en
sortent ma foi très bien alors pour les
informations pratiques c'est au prisme
samedi alors c'est aux prises le samedi
à dia le spectacle commence à 20h30 nous
fait arriver un petit peu avant
c'est dans la grande salle du prisme et
wayne réservé que la billetterie est le
site internet qui va s'infléchir ont pas
de l'écran voilà sur mesure sur le
facebook si vous avez des questions un
petit mail un petit à petit moule et
c'est cependant si même si on veut vous
rejoindre après si ça nous plaît pas de
souci les inscriptions sur ton forum de
maurepas au forum et vous alors le
théâtre c'est no comment
j'avais des amis qu'on faisait quand
j'avais 15 ans et du coup je suis
inscrit dans cette association chez
tandem et depuis j'y reste
parce que je me sens bien et parce qu'on
s'amuse bien voilà non maintenant si
vous aussi vous voulez découvrir le
théâtre fait commencer par voir le
spectacle 32 tandem pour ses 30 ans
mercy james calado les émissions de
plateau merci et je vous souhaite un bon
spectacle un vrai d'anniversaire à
l'association alors merci beaucoup
maintenant on passe de derrière le
rideau à dernière les crocs avec les
rubriques dans les salles
saint-quentinoise de nicolas gendry
[Musique]
cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret de la ville de
les clayes-sous-bois nous avons la
sortie nationale des spider man far from
home
nous vous conseillons d'aller voir le
dernier avenger engament avant d'aller
voir ce film car il contient des
spoilers important du dernier avengers
peter parker alias spider man qui
souhaitent partir en vacances en europe
rejoindre ses amis et tenter de
conquérir le coeur de la gêne mj la
terre est à nouveau en danger
à ce moment là et c'est le chef du chili
qui sera rappelée à notre super héros
spider man
elle est bien dangereux ni sympa du
quartier il se fait donc aidé par un
nouveau super-héros marvel par nist bec
les freins carnet par jake gyllenhall
afin de sauver le monde y est donc la
planète terre une mission l'on retrouve
donc énormément d'action de grands
effets spéciaux et toujours une note
d'humour dans les dialogues ce qui ce
texte
et ceci sera génial il vous plaira allez
donc le voir dès mercredi 3 juillet
est-ce que tu va assumer
[Musique]
des rapaces dans une volière de 12
mètres de haut des dents que l'on côtoie
à pied des rongeurs d'amérique du sud le
zoo safari de thoiry à aménager un
nouvel espace la white forest
les visiteurs peuvent se balader au
milieu de ces espèces pour certaines en
voie de disparition
l'objectif pour le parquet de
sensibiliser à leur protection
mathieu décombe au micro d'aurélie
henneton depuis quelques années le au
safari touahri on essaye de créer des
enclos d'immersion donc on avait déjà
l'enclos d'immersion avec les loriquets
avec les kangourous les lémuriens les
animaux plutôt d'amérique du sud avec
les alpagas et les mara
bien sûr la mini-ferme que tout le monde
adore et on a donc cette année une
nouvelle en une nouvelle zone avec les
rapaces en immersion lna en immersion
le parc se dirige vers une expansion de
la zone du parc à pied et donc on a
décidé ici dans cette belle forêt qu'ont
acquis naturel de créer une zone dédiée
à la forêt depuis 2014 france miniature
se lance dans l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
attraction chaque année pour cette
saison tu es le cirque des enfants et
qui prend place un espace de jeu
familial pour faire travailler son
équilibre et son adresse située au
dessus d'un parcours de voiture le tout
est accessible aux enfants à partir de 1
m
leurs parents aussi peuvent s'essayer
aux acrobaties il ya deux parties sur
cette attraction il ya une partie avec
un circuit automobile où les enfants
pilote leur voiture sur un décor un peu
bd et puis à 4 mètres au dessus du sol
les enfants montent dans un filet de 400
mètres carrés il y a vingt ateliers pour
jouer aux équilibristes trapézistes sur
le par a plus on est de fous plus on est
content pour rien c'est la devise du
festival content pour rien ce festival
itinérant se termine au parc de la
vallée du 5 au 7 juillet à
mantes-la-ville trois jours de concerts
et de spectacles en plein air avec des
artistes éclectiques venus de monde
entier l'événement met en avant la
musique et les arts de rue du 10 au 20
juillet c'est l'opération partir en
livres proposés par le ministère de la
culture est organisée par le centre
national du livre
le réseau des médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines ne pourrait pas
passer à côté de l'événement les
bibliothécaires vous invite donc à leur
grain de folie de spectacle de lecture
inattendu avec des animations et
maintenant direction paris pour un monde
imaginaire
[Musique]
jusqu'au 8 septembre le palais de tokyo
à paris présente une ville imaginaire un
laboratoire pour artistes ils sont une
cinquantaine à investir l'exposition
reportage dé paul bloqué de nos
confrères dia grand paris le palais de
tokyo se transforme en cité laboratoire
jusqu'au 8 septembre l'exposition
princesse des villes transforment les
salles du palais en un gigantesque
espace de création
le tout basé sur l'identité artistique
de sacs mégapole émergentes de la loin
des places fortes du milieu comme paris
ou berlin
ici c'est ma ni mexico lagos téhéran et
dacca qui insuffle donc un vent
d'originalité dans le palais princesse
des villes est une exposition découverte
c'est le résultat d'une prospection
qu'on amenait avec le palais de tokyo à
travers cinq mégapole 5 archives il dont
la taille et la densité rivalisent
souvent avec la taille de certains états
l'idée était de décentrer le regard du
palais de tokyo pour aller trouver des
nouvelles énergies d énergie qu on
connaissait parfois comme à mexico où la
scène est assez connu n'avait entendu
parler de l'émergence de nouvelles
scènes qu'on connaissait peu manille qui
a été une ville qui avait été déjà
visité de nombreuses fois par le palais
de tokyo et des villes qu'on ne
connaissait pas dont on a voulu aller
vous prospectez dans cette exposition le
visiteur se baladent au rythme du jour
et de la nuit à travers des lieux
mystérieux pour découvrir les créations
de la cinquantaine d'artistes et de
poser un rendez-vous immersif qui donne
l'impression de se retrouver dans une
ville imaginaire mais pas uniquement
on pourrait penser que c'est une ville
imaginaire mais c'est surtout un lieu
commun pour reprendre la pensée du
philosophe et poète edouard glissant un
lieu commun dans lequel la pensée du
monde rend compte les autres pensées du
monde et c'est vraiment ce qu'on a voulu
faire ici on n'a pas regrouper les
artistes par zones géographiques dont
les assembler pour créer des dialogues
des confrontations entre mais on a
cherché des artistes plutôt indépendant
du marché des artistes qui viennent
aussi du milieu du cinéma du théâtre de
la musique
de la performance donc on a voulu créer
comme ça un mix de milieux un mix de
monde un mix d'imaginaire princesse des
villes est à admirer jusqu'au 8
septembre au palais de tokyo
et c'est la fin de cette émission mais
aussi la fin de cette saison pour votre
site et choisir c'est un plaisir pour
moi de vous accompagner chaque semaine
n'oubliez pas retrouvé une édition
spéciale tout l'été sur notre antenne
bonnes vacances sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh